COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
we'll show how Stackdriver
can be used to profile
your production instances.
Will we have our performance
cake and eat it too?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it comes to
cloud-native applications,
understanding the performance
of production systems is
notoriously difficult.
See, you need
to profile that production code
so that you can get an accurate
view of performance.
But properly querying, logging,
and cataloging all of that data
usually has a significant
impact on your performance.
This is where Stackdriver
Profiler come in.
Stackdriver Profiler is a
statistical, low-overhead,
sampling-based profiler that
continuously gathers CPU usage
and memory allocation
information
from your production instances.
Plus, it's got a few other
nifty features as well.
It analyzes code execution
across all environments.
It uses gathered statistics
to minimize the impact
on the application.
And it helps you identify
performance problems
before they show up
on your monthly bill.
And it's pretty easy to use.
Now for example, this GoLink
app imports the Stackdriver
Profiler package,
sets up the Profiler,
and gets it running before
the rest of the application.
The data it collects is then
displayed in a flame chart
in the cloud
console, allowing you
to see exactly where your
execution time is going
and giving you the ability to
drill down and find hotspots
in your code.
But as we said before, this
type of insight isn't free.
So the question is,
what's this costing us?
Stackdriver Profiler works by
collecting data for 10 seconds
every one minute for
a single instance
of a configured service in a
single Google Compute Engine
Zone.
For example, if you've got
10 GCE instances running,
then the amortized overhead
of the CPU and heap allocation
profiling, at the time of data
collection, is less than 0.5%,
making it an affordable
option for always
on profiling in
production systems.
If you're interested in getting
started with the Stackdriver
APM, check out the article
linked in the description
below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
for more great "Cloud
Performance Atlas" content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]